[Music]
[Applause]
Brian scalabrini The White Mamba Celtics
analyst NBC Sports Boston and was on
that championship team in 2008
if I would have told you after game
three you were getting to game seven you
would have said what
Dan I believe you because this team is
so up and down the Celtic basketball
team now I it something happened this
season where I got to the point where I
just stopped guessing and I just say
Well they're gonna have to show me what
they're gonna do today because I just
ran out of the patience of trying to say
like all right well they figured it out
now they can build upon that I really
believe like this just the highs and
lows of this team is unlike anything
I've ever seen before all right when did
you know you were in trouble last night
um probably after Derek White made that
run in the third and I think Miami is
speaking of Caleb Martin he made two
really timely shots and I'm saying we're
not gonna win this game I I maybe got a
glimmer of hope at the start of the
fourth quarter when they ran a great
play out of the out of the quarter and
Tatum got a wide open layup and mist and
then they came down and hit a three at
that point I knew we were in trouble
what's the biggest question heading into
the off-season
probably Jalen Brown and um you know
will will they offer him the super max
contract well he's will I'm sure he'll
sign it if they offer it to him you know
last night um Tim Bond temps asked a
great question about Jalen Brown's
future and Jalen you know that's where
you give like the standard answer I'm
not really thinking about it right now
um I don't I don't know what the future
holds or I love this team we've been so
accomplished he didn't give an answer
that you would think and he didn't say
no he said I'm it's like I'm trying to
process all this but I just I wonder
what's going to go on there's been all
these talks about in the past about
those two guys then they're good then
when things are going bad they're not
good when things are going good they're
good so I wonder where all that lies it
you know this uh and I think it'll come
right around July but they don't
compliment each other normally when you
have two All-Stars there you know James
Harden can compliment Joel embiid or
clay compliments staff uh it feels like
a joker and Jamal Murray these two
players are very similar
would you keep Jalen Brown
but then there's a lot of Truth to what
you're saying but also
I mean they've been to four Conference
Finals in seven years would you keep
Jalen Brown yeah I mean I would I'm not
the one paying the bill you know they're
they went well let's take money out of
it right now I know oh yeah oh yeah
that's easy then that's easy okay if
it's not a if it's not a money thing
it's a it's a no-brainer but you know
like Celtics are in the tax they were in
the tax last year if they signed it
they're going to be deep into the tax I
think the Warriors are paying like eight
dollars for every dollar they spend
because they've been in a tax for eight
straight years like that's a problem in
the NBA yeah
uh but do you agree that they don't
compliment each other they basically are
similar types of players right but the
league now Dan is a defensive
versatility league and offensive
versatility it's a wing-driven league
now you might be right like LeBron and
A.D there's a there's a big and a wing
you know jokic and um and and Murray
Butler and annabayu you're right about
that but I think anybody in the NBA
would take two versatile wings that
could defend and rebound and they can
handle and run pick and roll so in this
day and age I wish they played better
together but I'm not saying like it's a
it's they've had a lot of success and
they can continue to have success but
they don't they don't handle the ball
well Brian
only when they're spacing as a team is
bad and I think Dan instead of looking
at it like they don't handle the ball
well I think they try to do too much at
times Tatum had the bad ankle Jalen
Brown thought I have to do more and
sometimes against Miami you don't want
to try to do more you want to try to do
less you want to you want to take one
dribble and move it and eventually wear
them out and they did it for three games
to get back in the series but this
particular style of play always comes
back to bite them when they're not
making shots talking to Brian scalabrini
the Boston Celtics analyst uh Joe
missoulis job safe
I would say he's I'll give you a 65 70
safe I think there's a lot of things
with the fact that he got thrusted into
this like I I heard there might be a lot
of guys leaving to go with imeiodoka who
hasn't hired really that many assistant
coaches down in Houston so so some they
they might get a new staff they might
have some guys at some former players
and some former head coaches I think to
be honest with you Dan to give him a
fair shot you've got to build a staff
that that hat and I I think these guys
were great but they lost David stodemar
halfway through the season will hardy
they lost him last year he made doka
they lost from last year
um Damon Stoudemire they lost this year
I just think you got to put a a great
veteran staff around a first year coach
yeah I agree you got to have that guy
who has the experience and you know I
thought what spolster did I I don't you
know when we get into out coached I
think that there are times where he was
far more tactical spolster is very
underrated still which which is kind of
amazing I think he's a Hall of Fame head
coach but but it felt like he was making
the Right Moves for a team that
shouldn't have won this Eastern
Conference Finals
no no I mean you can make an argument
Dan that they shouldn't even have been
here but you know I think he coaches the
guy's heart now this is the thing that's
really interesting about spoaster all we
hear nowadays players league players
league players league players dictate
this players dictate that you can't
coach them too hard like that's not what
you want to do with your Superstar
player except for Air Expo because he
has backing from Pat Riley so I give him
all the credit in the world because I
think he's a brilliant coach and I also
give him all the credit in the world
because I grew up where coaches yelled
at us all the time like that's just a
generation that I played in so I think
that he has a huge Advantage knowing
that he could get into guys and they
might bark back but he barks back and
it's never oh my God he lost the locker
room no one ever said Eric spoaster lost
a locker room or he pushes him too hard
but Eric spoaster will also say well we
do ain't for everybody and it it just
works for this particular group
if I said you could have Jimmy Butler
Jason Tatum
I'm taking Tatum yeah I love Jimmy
Butler though I do love Jimmy but I love
his cow how she's a gamer but you go
with a guy that has the talent
what was it like right before tip-off
oh my gosh I've been in that building a
lot there's no I think the fact that
they came back from down uh 03 made the
biggest difference the crowd was loaded
they were ready Paul Pierce was getting
them hyped up they they respond to the
old guy the old Celtics more than any
place I've been in other places you know
you go to other these other places they
show the the guy he waves and everyone
you know gives a little bit of a cheer
man the crowd was amazing and but you
know what it was amazing in game five
against Philly they had it done it was
amazing in game five against Atlanta it
was a dud it was amazing last year
against uh the Golden State Warriors in
game six it was a dud a lot of times
this group for whatever reason and I
don't I'm not going to get into the
generational thing or the personality
thing but when the crowd is unbelievable
a lot of times this group has swung and
missed I don't understand this logic
you're of the new age
you're shooting threes and you're
getting down by double digits so you
continue to shoot threes and you have no
chance of coming back is there any logic
to getting a two or going to the hoop
maybe getting a foul on somebody help me
understand a team that goes nine for 42.
and that's your that's your offensive
game plan yeah you know what
I I don't I've had conversations with
Joe Missoula about it and by the way
he's not he's not that the way that he's
abrasive with the media he's not that
way and just outside of that but I've
had conversations about it and I and I
really believe like when the Celtics
drive into the teeth of the defense and
get threes they're different threes but
you know a lot of times they settle for
that one pass shot they wanted they want
to take the first shot that's what they
say if the shots open we want to take it
so you can't I think I think basketball
is more art than science I think it's
more like there's a you know if if me
and you were playing together Dan and I
threw it to you and you threw her back
to me and I drove and I kicked it to you
I feel like you have a better chance of
making that shot because you've got
involved into the game but you know
that's not their philosophy that's the
way they want to play they think that
the threes will eventually all balance
out but in the playoffs you can get down
O3 you can come back and then you can
lose a game seven you know by you know
double digits and never come back from
it because relying on that three well
that's why the Nuggets stand out the
Nuggets will make an extra pass if you
watch them play they're going to always
make one more pass and not many teams do
that so you're saying that yes and I
think well here they are in the NBA
Finals you need to do that because you
might have a good shot when I can get a
great shot by somebody and if you're
trusting your team and everybody gets
involved that's why Butler usually gets
everybody involved and then he takes
over later in the game Joker gets
over usually later in the game and I
think that's that's the tribute to great
a great team player understanding you
get going I'll get going and then we'll
win this thing no Dan no question about
it even last year the Golden State
Warriors passed the ball so much more
last year than they did this year like
this year we saw Jordan pool Steph Curry
Klay Thompson dribbling around looking
for their own shot like I don't
understand it it's why the NBA doesn't
adapt more towards ball movement bald
movement is to keep the defenses are so
sophisticated guys are so good they know
Tendencies one thing you can't guard
against is that is that ball movement
and not just passing the ball around the
perimeter getting to the T to the
defense drawing uh people kicking it out
and then what you said extra passed who
doesn't love playing basketball like
that so I think the teams that pass the
best in the playoffs are the teams that
are in the finals and I thought last
year the teams that played the best ball
movement uh I would think Miami Miami
last year was better at moving the ball
than the Celtics were last year but
Celtics defense was better but typically
the ball the team that moves basketball
the most is a team that's going to end
up going to the finals and have a
tremendous amount of success did you
ever go as Larry Bird for Halloween
nah
I I went as uh
Kurt ramvis one time that was good okay
okay
all you need is the glasses in the Laker
jersey yeah and he taped them he had
that tape I had to tape them I don't
know if that if he broke him why he had
tape there but I taped them so I I did
that I had a wig and everything it was a
great look hey good to talk to you enjoy
the off season thanks for joining us
Gotta Dance here that's Brian scalabrini
the white Mamba Celtics analyst NBC
Sports Boston